nearly 300 billion dollars that's how
much money the Federal Trade Commission
estimates workers could be missing out
on each year because of non-compete
agreements interestingly we see wages
depressed not just for people who are
directly subject to non-competes but
even for workers that are not a new
proposal from the FTC would ban
non-compete clauses at the federal level
following states that have already made
them unenforceable the FTC thinks this
is going to be really good for workers
it will make companies have to think
differently maybe more creatively about
how they're going to retain people
here's what a federal ban on
non-competes could mean for workers and
businesses and why it faces challenges
non-competes typically restrict workers
from jumping to competitors after they
leave a company for example this is a
non-compete clause for Amazon from 2018.
it specifies an amount of time that
workers have to wait before moving to a
competitor others can also bar people
from working in a certain geographic
area employers include these in
contracts because they want to protect
confidential information they want to
protect Trade Secrets proprietary
information that might be everything
from a scientific formula to a list of
customers the FDC estimates that almost
20 percent of workers in the U.S are
affected by non-compete agreements that
includes people across Industries and
positions from business Executives to
lower wage workers who likely have less
access to proprietary information
regulation for enforcing them right now
is entirely up to States but the Biden
Administration has pushed for Federal
Regulation workers should be free to
take a better job if someone offers it
the FDC says that non-compete clauses
hurt the U.S labor market and that
eliminating them would give workers more
mobility in their industry which could
increase wages non-competes mean that
somebody can't go to another company
where they might be offered a higher
salary or a higher wage it also means
that they can't go and get an offer from
another company and come back to their
employer and say Hey you know here's my
offer will you meet it it doesn't give
them the means to negotiate for higher
pay after a ban on non-compete clauses
for hourly workers in Oregon in 2008
wages increased by two to three percent
on average something similar happened in
Hawaii in 2012 when wages for new tech
hires went up by four percent after the
state introduced a ban in the sector
proponents of a federal ban say it could
also Pro entrepreneurship by freeing
employees up to join a new business or
start their own the ftc's idea is that
by giving people the freedom to do that
without these restrictions it will be
both you know good for individuals and
also good for the economy but it's a
little more complicated for companies on
one hand the potential ban could give
companies a broader hiring pool and more
chances to bring on talent but opponents
of the ban also say it offers less
protection for Trade Secrets which
aren't fully covered by laws when I've
asked lawyers about this they say yeah
but it's It's tricky because Trade
Secrets laws you can only impose after
the fact and you can't Monitor and track
what they're telling other people or
what they're using so you know they say
that non-competes really are the only
way they they can know that their
information is being protected if
adopted companies would need to rescind
these Clauses from any contract and
inform employees passed and present the
U.S Chamber of Commerce says that the
ftc's proposed ban is blatantly unlawful
no matter what rule the FTC comes out
with they will probably be challenged in
court about the parameters or even
whether they have the authority to
create a rule like this the FTC says it
does we're confident that the the text
and instructor of the FTC act gives us
clear authority to do this but the
proposal still has some time before it
gets to that point it has to go through
60 days of public comment first where
anyone can offer feedback then the
agency can formally make the proposed
rule a regulation at the moment it's
very Broad and it basically applies to
any non-compete the final rule may be
different from them they may modify some
of it the public comment period ends
March 10th